here is the setup I have a balance and
two identical beakers which I fill with
exactly the same amount of water except
in one of the beakers there's a
submerged ping-pong ball tethered to the
base of the beaker and in the other
there's an identically sized ball but
made of acrylic so it's denser than
water and it's supported by a thread now
I want you to make a prediction if I
were to release this balance and allow
it to rotate freely which way do you
think it would tip towards the acrylic
ball towards the ping-pong ball or would
it remain perfectly balanced you can
make your selection by clicking on one
of the on-screen annotations or clicking
a link in the description if they're
both displacing the same amount like I
think it won't rotate so yes it will not
rotate stay balanced the ping-pong ball
does have mass I'll be it not very much
I would predict that this end will will
sink I almost feel like this end would
lift because it's lighter than but it
wouldn't be pulling because it's
tethered to the lever I don't know I'm
thinking it would go this way
I'm thinking because of the tension
that's pulling this up so I guess if
you're summing the forces isn't as more
so then this is gonna rest
no all right so just switch my mind I
want to go what this one's gonna raise
but I mean it seems like this shouldn't
be contributing any force to this side
because it's suspended and the forces
are balanced that means you'd have more
of a normal force on this side and it
won't tip that way it'll tip down on the
back on both sides both side yeah that
is so weird
so now you think it's gonna go up on the
side hold on a sec you ready 3 2 1
member